je pensais que tu me rappellerais pas
pourquoi pas on se revoit je te demande
un truc alorsre collèg on se en service
non par que Mo après tiens Stéphan Assur
il s'est fait serrer dans un bar Hugo
avec 10 g ta colonbienne tiens reste au
chic le bom où il a associé à un Serbe
quel jour aujourd'hui bref le jeudi
cette soirée menu spécial et tout B
merci j'irai pas plus loin et bien sûr
ça vient pas de moi bien
sûr ça ça
va c'est pas une bonne question
ça tu me demandes si ça va à part ça
mais à part quoi à part que je suis ta
fille je suis petite comme ma mère je
t'ai vu trois fois dans ma vie ça fait
que de la merde ça c'est pas des
souvenirs ou alors tu veux dire à part
ma mère mais tuas vu dans quel état elle
est je la ti bout de bras je suis n
jeavais déjà sur le
dos alors ok on est tous les de pas
pareil
commissaire moi c'est darwi je
figurante que de la
merde ça va au Nive de la merde j'ai
l'habite tout savoir je
sa tu sais
quoi tu sais
rien tu as
raison